hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the theater
okay so this game is this game was
suggested to me um very recently in my
new slew cuz a lot of you been
suggesting games to me and I really
appreciate it but um first off check to
see if I played the game first okay
again I'm getting a lot of repeat
suggestions but um this one popped up
and it looks really interesting and it
says 1993 but I don't think that's right
because um I think it's based off of a
creepypasta if I'm not mistaken I didn't
read it
there was a creepypasta linked with it
but all right here we go hello that's
awfully dark oh okay oh hi hello okay
can I get out huh oh okay spacebar was
that oh these a movie put okay sooo
nothing strange about this I'm just
gonna go and see in a movie you know
sometimes I go to the movies by myself I
may stop after this game anyway
well hey we're I'm a movie damn it hi
harding isla bone to pick with you I
didn't even get to enjoy the movie what
the hell is going on huh
well I guess out was a great movie or
something yeah about that I'm getting
kind of weirded out I'm a feeling
something's gonna start changing
if I keep looping through this what's
the UH what's the what's the deal what's
the deal bruh what's the deal what is
going on I'm not I'm confused I'm lost
and confusing it changed
so they went Everett where's my favorite
movie Usher you're not there I don't
think you can trick me I know you're not
there wah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha Oh what
huh
something happened what wah wah
then and the [ __ ] what the hell is going
on ah ah I don't know I am I'm not
exactly sure what does happening here ah
you go Afrin I can't move okay you
you gotta hell and you die mr. movie
Usher Jesus balls how about you go enjoy
yourself
Oh turns turns turn turns turns turns
was turns means an Arctic Tern hi dick
hi those aren't words that's space
invaders you're talking space invaders
man some wrong with your jaw I'm gonna
go this way you go stay away way
way way far from me what was that I saw
flashes double what was that what hi hi
my movies wha-what happened huh what
happened ah ah what happened did it end
hang on
I think it just ended I think oh yeah
what hey I gotta get back in there hang
on like she is loaded ready I'm gonna
try to expedite oh you going around you
I'm not talking to you ever and then
talking to you at all you screw yourself
I'm breaking into the movie whoa oh I
did something ha ha I did something oh
boy
I did something bad what did i do what
did i do what did i do we're gone what
the ha okay that's the same as before
I'm just never gonna talk to I'm not
gonna talk to him I told I do I'm not
gonna talk to him cuz talking to him is
the key to my destruction he is hi is
that a [ __ ] yes son of a [ __ ] ah
creepy
[ __ ] yeah just screw off maybe he was
doing like a pattern that I was supposed
to remember around care
I don't even care you screwed yourself
I'm never talking to you ever ever ever
I'm pretty sure that was a mistake I
made before you obviously are a
diabolical demon from the fifth
dimension of you get a little worse for
wear there buddy
hey you go away you go I you go away if
it doesn't do anything different now I'm
gonna be concerned please okay go away
mr. movie Esther what kind of weirdo
theater is this anyway there's not even
any popcorn on sale semester I would
love some refreshments
are you gonna closer to me every time I
brew dude I'm not talking to him ever
ever I'm not talking to him no never
I swear that [ __ ] can go away and die
in a fire hey hey hey I want to go home
ha ha about another theater I want to go
home I didn't even know what this guy's
name is I'm pretty sure he's the center
of the creepypasta
just gonna be careful
I'm hoping that this eventually does
something Oh No okay nothing seems to be
happening differently I'm not exactly
sure what I'm supposed to do I'm
confused to say the least
there just seems to be a rousing round
of applause gonna go this way
here maybe maybe I don't know maybe I
just wait why is he why does he turn
like completely black when I face this
direction that's weird
what's it wait wait a minute some goes
weird maybe it's just a lighting change
I think it's just the lighting okay
nothing happen I'm gonna continue
looping through here until something
different happens which I don't think
anything different is going to happen
I'm just not sure what what why my
father to death get up here otherwise
bolted do it doesn't make anything turns
turns maybe a spinning huh why is it
pitch black where'd he go there is he's
right there I see you freaky bastard
what am i spotted uh turns turns turns
turns turns turns turns turns turns
turns turns burns what are the turns
mean what are the turns main
what's over here come over here
Java [ __ ] I want to go out are those
supposed to be like buildings really is
that what there's about to be I don't
know creepy [ __ ] oh my god oh it's
messing with my brain I think like a the
constant looping music is like sending a
data pattern into my brain melting it
from the inside I need music it's just a
sound my own so someone banging on the
low end of a piano over it over and over
and then distorting it out okay
something's gotta give something's gotta
give something's gotta give man
something's gotta give
sounds gotta give one more time one more
time one more time then i'ma talk to him
ah ah ah
look I'll kill you Achille oh man why I
must be doing something wrong cuz if
their closes out the game again I'll be
I'll be very upset okay
aha with that happened before
oh yeah that's right I remember I missed
that step I forgot that that happened so
uh what do I do about that now what I do
about that [ __ ]
so um yeah look at the music stop I
start up again what is going on uh
echoes okay I don't know what the hell
that was all about but the longer I was
in it the more I thought I was gonna
lose my mind it was so weird I don't get
it
okay so the guy who sent me the email
also said that there was a secret ending
I couldn't obviously I couldn't find it
so if you guys want to try it for
yourself the link is in the description
below please check it out I'll try to
get to the ending I mean that huh it's
just the atmosphere that game was just
so wrong everything about it just felt
weird ooh okay though anyway um thank
you all so much for watching the link is
in the description below if you want to
play for yourself click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
Oh
but